we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 david p
here's a very interesting voicemail now
i have spoken about this in the past
i've spoken before about a so-called
in-cell component to some of the mass
shootings okay some
here's a caller who is picking up on
something that may be true i'm going to
play it for you and then i want to get
your thoughts listen to this
hey david logan here i was just curious
about your opinion on something so it
seems like most the shooters that go
around and shoot up schools are mostly
sexually frustrated bullied young
individuals do you think if prostitution
was legalized in america and certain
individuals could have access to certain
kinds of things do you think that might
have an impact on reducing the amount of
shootings in america i mean listen the
question is
if the shooters were having sex would
they not be shooters that they at the at
the fundamental core of the question
it's
that question
would having i mean really really it's
even more than that right it's not just
inability to find typically the shooters
are heterosexual males so i'll use the
term girlfriend although we could be
talking about a partner significant
other generally speaking
it does seem as though
a lot of these shooters are
not
establishing romantic relationships in
what might be a typical way given their
ages
and so the question fundamentally is if
they had a girlfriend or if they just
had more social connections would it
probably
reduce the number of shootings i think
the answer is it very well might
but what do you do about that and
regardless
should people who if they can't find a
girlfriend are going to shoot up a
school have access to guns like it
doesn't change the gun situation
but i think it's completely fair and
really it's responsible to say
this is such a complicated and major
issue
i talk about gun safety but we shouldn't
only be talking about guns
we
you know when the right says well we've
got to deal with mental health yeah
let's deal with it so you republicans
should stop voting against bills to
better fund access to mental health care
let's increase access to mental health
care in the country but let's also
require
a psyche valve for having a gun so maybe
we can identify more people who should
be directed instead of to getting a
handgun or a rifle
to a therapist of some kind let's do all
of the above should we consider
you know not this whole eliminate all
doors but does it make sense to have
police do evaluations of schools and say
here's five recommendations that could
be done to increase security
do it of course do all those things but
the guns have to be a part of it and
additionally this element of well what
is the the connection between lack of
social connection lack of romantic
relationships and people doing these
things let's explore it anecdotally it
does seem as though this this is a
correlation factor
although the causation is much more
difficult to ascertain ascertain so
interesting voicemail many of you have
emailed in about essentially the same
issue we have a fantastic bonus show for
you today
joe biden is pointing to an assault
weapons ban
as a quote rational option for gun
control and gun safety we're going to
discuss it on the bonus show number two
um we have never been great at recycling
plastic and there are states trying a
new approach which we're going to
discuss on today's bonus show and in
addition the manager of the san
francisco giants
is um
taking a break
from his anthem protest
because of memorial day we're going to
talk about that we're going to talk
about what he's been doing gabe kepler
um and see what people think and much
more when i am joined by producer pat on
today's bonus show you can get access to
the bonus show by signing up at
joinpackman.com
alex jones doesn't want you to do this
oh the bonus show where you want to make
money everybody else that makes money to
find themselves is bad yeah alex jones
in fact in fact finds everything i do
predatory that is a freaking predator he
doesn't like me but
i recommend signing up at joinpakman.com
and you can use the coupon code big
voting 22
to get a sizable discount i will see you
on the bonus show in a moment or
otherwise back on tomorrow's program